foreign
how do I and my husband prepare for the
transition to being parents and how do I
personally handle um the fear of losing
my marital relationship as it is now as
well as handle the fear of losing myself
there is zero percent chance you hang on
to your marriage as it is right now and
that's a good thing
[Music]
it's John with the Dr John deloney's
show
the greatest mental health and marriage
and parenting podcast ever
ever so glad that you joined us uh
listen it's I'm starting to sound like a
broken record and I get that and for
those of you who don't know what a
broken record is uh ask uh chat gbt
it'll it'll fill you in but
um one of the greatest gifts you can
give us costs no money costs nothing
other than like 0.2 seconds of your time
hit the Subscribe button and it kicks
this show up into the algorithms so that
the digital Warlords will put this in
front of other people
um so they can see it
um and hit you hit the thumbs up or the
like or whatever the new
bam Fandango thing is I don't know how
to just say that you like it and add
your five star reviews such a help such
a help
um and it cost you nothing and uh I'm
grateful for you but more importantly
there's a single mom with trying to
figure out what day it is and she feels
lost and it helps kick the show up into
her feed she never heard of me before
and um it gets this information in your
Journeys in front of other people who
need it so thank you so so so much
um do we have a whole gang out here
today are you all in the same family
oh man we're probably talking a lot
about sex so this will be weird for
everybody so y'all y'all enjoy
yourselves
um all right let's go oh real quick
speaking of that um hang on
so uh this is when uh this week uh the
all these different shows coming in a
row about sex and intimacy and talking
about sex and sex and then more sex and
one of my best friends on planet Earth
my oldest friends in the world his name
is Mike
um a guy that I just love dearly he's
like he's a brother to me for years and
years and years he just texted me and
said dude who on this planet ever
decided you should be hosting shows
about sex have you even had it
well you know what they say what's that
those that can't do teach
well played Mike and kelly well played
that hurts in my soul
and for those of you wondering who are
like 25 and you're like man I can't wait
till I grow up and then I get friends
who this is just this is the rest of
your life all right let's go to will in
St Louis what up Will how we doing man
good uh thanks for having me of course
dude what's happening
uh not too much um
thanks for having me and uh just um I've
been listening to you ever since you
took your first call on the Ramsey Show
for real yeah dude for a while and uh
yeah I I've listened to every episode of
your podcast and uh dude I really enjoy
that man thank you so much my mom
doesn't even listen to that many man
you're like in the Sons of Anarchy gang
dude I appreciate that so what's up man
um so my question today is how do I
balance the need to provide financially
for my family along with the need to be
present for them
um background is I uh am married uh
married for 12 years I have three kids
who will be six four and two over the
next few months
I grew up in a very financially unstable
household
we were a blended family I am one of
seven siblings my dad was a
self-employed mechanic for most of my
childhood and was a sole income provider
for my family my stepmom stayed home to
take care of the family
my dad never made much money it was
never talked about directly with us but
the signs were there now that I'm older
and I think about it
um and I know that my like I know my
parents filed bankruptcy at least twice
maybe
um before I was a teenager
I never went without foods but uh now
that I'm older and I looked back and I
and I I think about what we ate and
everything it was because it was very
cheap meals um hail real quick real
quick
I want I want to make sure you know this
is is not a math problem and what I mean
by that is this it's very easy to look
back and say we had money problems as a
kid and so now I'm gonna struggle with
when is enough how much money do I make
all those but those are math problems
questions
I need you to know in a home with a
bankruptcy
that's like living in the middle of a
hurricane
and so money has made its way into your
soul as the reason why dad's always
angry my mom won't talk to me what
brother and sister are always fighting
like you see what I'm saying so it it
became it it grows tentacles into all
these different aspects in your life
does that make sense
yeah um I kind of don't need to finish
the rest of my stuff
sorry so um I I can't when somebody says
bankruptcy like it that is it's like
dropping a bomb in somebody's home and
doing it two or three times the shame
the failure the I'm not the dad I could
have been and most dads of that
generation didn't have the word didn't
have the skills to say hey guys
um my business fell through what they
had the skills to do was to sit down on
the recliner and yell and scream it or
be silent right and then moms like my
husband's a loser and I gotta deal with
this and I'm stuck with these kids all
of that energy gets transferred into
kids
and they're left wondering what did I do
to screw this house up
yeah um my dad was never I don't
remember him being angry it was more
he'd get up at like 4 a.m go to work
work all day come home at like eight or
nine eat dinner and then fall asleep on
the couch like we never did anything
because she was always working and when
he was home he was sleeping right so
um but uh and you know you know that
that okay we talk about your old man all
day I don't talk about you okay so tell
me where you are right now
so um
so I learned from a very young age that
I needed to work to basically provide
for myself
um I mean I was 12 years old and I was
mowing lawn delivering papers same here
same here same here I was making close
to 600 bucks a month as a 12 year old
um just hustling fast forward to now
um I got married at 20 to my high school
sweetheart um she came from an upper
middle class is she awesome yes yes
um
she came from an upper middle class
family and I thought it was my
responsibility to provide for her on
this uh so she had the same lifestyle
growing up
um
um and then uh we did that the wrong way
got it got into a lot of debt
um and um fast forward uh for the first
10 years of our marriage last couple
we've been working on getting out of it
but um when my oldest was born uh that
year I was on track to make about 28 to
30 000
um and I took a job that jumped it up to
70.
but that also came with a lot of work
and a lot of travel uh this year
um I'm on track to make 130 okay
um
but I have this need in my head that
it's not enough and I I
want to call it a pathological need to
make sure that we don't go backwards and
my kids don't experience uh the
childhood
that I did and uh
I can't
get emotional
um I can't figure out when to stop and
yeah dude
um so I I'm holding this up here like I
wrote down all my notes you while you
were talking
you need a metric for enough when is it
that's the note I wrote myself okay so
you're already there
um let me tell you what happened in my
house okay because you and I have a very
similar story my dad never declared
bankruptcy but he was a policeman and
then he switched over to become a
minister and so uh we were hounded by
money my whole life okay this idea um
and I like you I was working since I was
11 or 12 mowing lawns
um and working maintenance at the local
church and I was always just doing odd
jobs all over the place
um this year so I I spent the last 20
years of my life working in education in
some shape form or fashion whether
University or a public schools or
whatever and the last couple of years
when I took this job with Ramsey
Solutions it's the first time I've ever
had the opportunity to the more you work
the more we'll pay you
like the more you create things and help
other people that bring Revenue in the
more you can make
and I felt like uh dragon was Unleashed
in me
and it was this past you may have heard
me say this I may have talked about this
on this show
it was not this Christmas but the last
one
I went downstairs I was sick I was
trying to get my workout in and my wife
came down and she's like what are you
doing
and I was like well I gotta get I gotta
work out because then I gotta go do this
and then I got
and she said something that was um kind
of a shape shifter for me and I've spent
the last year trying to figure out how
to live out of what she said okay here's
what she said
she said
if my life is a pie chart your good
looks that that
part of the pie chart is full
any pathological psychotic workouts that
you need to do above that is because of
your ego not because of me
and I always thought I need to be in
great shape for my wife that was like a
that was a story I carried with myself
she won't love me if right and then she
said and while we're here
you've written two books you've done
this you've done this you've done this
we've made more money in the past
however many months than our families
could have ever wrapped their head
around
and you won't stop and then she said
this the we need more money bucket is
completely full anything beyond this is
about you and your ego and what you
think you need do not blame us and dude
that shook me to my core
because I was doing all I was doing all
this hustling and running and running
hustling
under the guise of I'm providing for my
family and I never want my kids to
experience what I experienced right same
as you is that fair
yeah yeah absolutely here is here is the
I want to Short Circuit a year of your
life for you so that I can tell you
where I've landed right now and I want
you to know like I've met with wise
people I've gone to visit people I've
read books my wife and I have had
Retreats I've done all the stuff right
ultimately
you and your wife have to sit down and
do the hard work and it's harder than
just going to get it getting another job
another job another job it's asking
yourselves what life do we want to
create for our family
and it that is what kind of house do we
want to have as a dream what kind of
house would be great would be fun
how do we want to feel every day
like what kind of energy do we want in
our home do you want an electric energy
do you want a warm and peaceful energy
what what are we going for here
and then the hard work for a guy like
you and for a guy like me is we have to
then say okay
I've got to stop working so much because
that's cutting into what we both decided
we want for our our lives does that make
sense
yes yeah and then the other magic is
uh and Dave Ramsay's helped me a lot
with this is keeping in mind the ratios
because if you're not careful your life
will just continue to expand with the
more money you make
you get what I'm saying
um and so can you get a raise and keep
your lifestyle the same I can't I
actually have to intentionally step My
Lifestyle down a notch I've got to go
backwards a little bit
um and so every time we have a success
I'm gonna actually buy fewer things that
next month and that just helps me to
keep myself honest that's just the way
I've learned to manage it but can we
keep our life this can we stay a camera
Corolla family through the next raise
and the raise after that and the race
after that so we can build actual wealth
you see what I'm saying
yeah all of this circles around that
word that is we do not have a psychology
for in our culture and that's enough
everything is built on growth getting
bigger getting more can you expand why
aren't you are you gonna buy a business
do you have a rent house yet we do not
have a word in our culture for enough
because that word feels like failure
right
yeah it does yeah so let me ask you do
you have an emergency fund
no um we're still paying off debt I'm
down to about 30 000 left out of a
hundred and twenty that's incredible
dude dude just for a second applaud
yourself man
applaud that's incredible now I will
tell you this is my personal opinion if
you owe somebody money
you're buy actually I think it's science
your body won't let use rest because it
knows
it knows you're not safe it knows that
just it takes one layoff one car wreck
one something and you were right back
where you were when you were 12.
I believe that with all my heart that
you cannot be fully without anxiety
until you owe nobody any money so what
I'll tell you is keep your foot jammed
into the floor until you get that money
paid off and I'm gonna tell you to keep
that sucker running until you have an
emergency fund because I've been with
you where you are and until I've got
some money that I feel safe I can sit on
for a minute
then I keep feeling like I gotta grind I
gotta grind gotta grind gotta grind
so you're on the right path my brother
you're right there you're right there
but I'd love you and your wife to begin
to have the what do we want this thing
to look and feel like and how do we
build that world because it might be
that you go back to making seventy
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
dollars when you owe nobody anything and
you have a full emergency fund you can
kind of do what you want
how does that sound does that sound
crazy
it does because I I don't know if I can
I don't know how to switch that part of
my brain off like you gotta hey you
gotta it's not a switch it's not a
switch stop thinking of it that way it's
not on or off
and it's not like a a puzzle piece
you're trying to find this is training
your body because your body loves you
dude and is trying to take care of you
and it remembers having nothing it
remembers the fights and The Angst and
dead that was never home and if I I
don't wanna I don't wanna talk trash
about your old man but he was it was an
addict he was addicted to work he was
actually addicted to being busy
because he spun his wheels really really
hard he just never went anywhere
right and that tells me he worked it was
a really hard worker and also did not
listen to wisdom it was a really hard
worker and didn't have anybody in his
corner with him that was like what are
you doing why are you doing it like that
why don't you do this because that's a
guy that you point in the right
direction with some grip on the tires
and he's gonna go really far really fast
see what I'm saying
yeah yeah and yeah so your body knows
all that and it's just trying to keep
you safe man and so what you have to do
it's not a matter of finding a switch
it's a matter of slowly over time
teaching your body yeah that was not
safe
and I've got forty thousand dollars in
the bank I don't owe anybody anything
we're good
and if the air conditioner goes out the
biggest fight my wife and I are going to
have is who's going to call the the
repair person
not can we eat this month and when your
body takes off on you you're gonna
practice feeling it and going oh man
there it goes yep I do I owe thirty
thousand dollars in credit cards or
student loans or whatever I I borrowed
I'm gonna get that knocked out
and then you're gonna go about getting
it knocked out
I will also say this my brother I think
that the word balance is a myth I don't
think it's real I don't think it exists
I have found great success in my life
living by Seasons there's just Seasons
when I got to wear a coat because it's
freezing there's just Seasons when uh
Suns out guns out I don't wear
sleeveless shirts just because no it
would look like an idiot but you know
I'm saying like there's just different
clothes that you wear for different
seasons and so there you're in a season
right now where your body is screaming
at you we're not safe we owe people
money awesome listen to it run get that
stuff paid off as fast as you can your
kids are going to be okay if you
sacrifice one more year of grinding it
out so they can have
the rest of their lives with parents who
are stress-free when it comes to money
now you're talking
and if you were able to get around town
in a used Camry or used a cord or a used
pickup when you were making 28 and 30
000 you could get around town with the
same truck when you're making 130 000
when you're trying to meet other goals
you don't have to move up to another car
you don't have to move up to Phil
whatever whatever whatever
my dirty little secret is when I was
making thirty three thousand dollars a
year I had a 2001 truck
and now that I'm making way more than
thirty thousand dollars I have a 2006
truck and I'll buy something new at some
point but right now I'm that's just
getting me to work it back and I'm fine
and so I'm not letting my lifestyle get
grow concurrently with the money I'm
making because I want to change my
family tree I want to change my legacy
and all that started with a conversation
my wife had with me and said we have
enough
stop running I want my husband back
and that's a hard hard lesson my friend
it's not a switch something that you
practice hang on the line I'm gonna send
you a copy of on your past change your
future I want you and your wife to read
that together and I'm also going to send
you all the questions for humans cards
for the kids and I want you to practice
not being a dad who works so hard he
just collapses everything gets up and
goes and gives and goes again and goes
again and should be a dad who practices
talking to his kids at breakfast
and surprising him on Saturdays and
engaging with him for breakfast or for
dinner or whatever and learning how to
have conversations with them so you
learn to love being in their presence
and they love learning to be in yours
cool thank you so much my brother we'll
be right back
I've got a word from our sponsor better
help listen I've been on both ends of
therapy in my life I've gotten it myself
and I've walked people through it and
I've seen the benefits from both sides
when someone owns their past and the
cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right let's go out to Sarah in
Florida what up Sarah how we doing
oh just just partying here how are you
doing dude me too if by parting you mean
I'm drinking water and I'm at work but
what's up
yeah hiding from my dogs
um
so
um I have a question for you are you a
job are you a dog mom say no say no uh
uh
I used to think
they're a pet owner I'm a pet owner I
love it okay all right so you're a
former dog parent who's transitioned to
pet owner what's up because yep because
my husband and I are expecting our first
baby in May so Mike you're gonna be a
human parent wow a human parent yes
super excited time out time out real
quick to the YouTubers okay relax
you don't know I love my I know you love
your pet you're not a pet parent there's
no such thing you're a pet owner and
that's great I love my dog often more
than any of my other family members but
I'm not a parent of a dog I'm a parent
of two kids all right transition back to
Sarah what up okay she's having a kid
congratulations when is your baby coming
yeah see May May 19th is her due date oh
it's a her
it's a beautiful baby girl I know she's
beautiful already I don't even need to
see her
so is this all about narcissistic
personality disorder so um I think that
you should possibly consider John uh as
a as a name that's a beautiful
daughter's name Johna John John anyway
okay so tell me how can I help how can I
help
um so I guess my my question is
um how do I and my husband prepare for
the transition to being parents and how
do I personally handle um the fear of
losing my marital relationship as it is
now as well as handle the fear of losing
myself as we transition into parental
roles
such a great question all right to
answer your first question how do you
prepare for being a parent
um I want you to get a 30 pack of of
like Miller tall boys and I want you to
go stand in traffic and that's the best
that's the best way you can prepare for
what's coming okay and hopefully I'm
just kidding don't do any of those
things I just said all right so
oh man how honest can I be with you
um there is zero percent chance you hang
on to your marriage as it is right now
and that's a good thing and there's zero
percent chance you hang on to your life
and your autonomy
as you know it now and that's a great
thing your husband's Gonna Change you're
gonna change your house is going to
change everything about you what you
know about yourself is going to change
all of that is going to be change it's
going to change and it's going to be
good you will lose yourself
okay and I think this is just my
personal opinion I don't have any signs
to back this up it's just me sitting
with countless people
I believe that if you take away like
hormonal dysregulation and all that
chaos that happens physiologically
I think one of the core mental health
challenges with new parents is them
trying to
um take their old life and somehow drag
it into the future
with their new kid
and what happens is you end up every
second of every day you're comparing he
used to be do this and now he's like
this she used to look like this and now
it's like this we used to have this much
time and my wife used to just want to
make out all the time and now she falls
asleep at 7 15. like all those things
happen and in and of themselves they're
fantastic
it's when you start comparing them to
the old stuff all of the time and you
create this narrative that somehow we're
broken somehow we're not working right
somehow we've got just got to get back
on track not realizing you're in a
totally different train going a totally
different direction now does that make
sense
yeah yeah it does here's the best way I
can describe it this may be a terrible
analogy
um have you ever been to like a water
park
oh yeah okay all right so I love water
park oh yeah you're in Florida I love
water parks and I love I hate heights
but I love the water right like the
highest one and you just hey you just
you shoot off and you fly right and
you're just kind of bumping it barely as
you go down imagine flying off that and
then grab it on and hang it on
you're gonna pull your shoulders out of
socket that water is on a jet stream and
it's going to blast you in the face it's
going to sandpaper your skin off it's
going to make it where you can't breathe
or you can jump off that thing and just
let go
most people jump off that thing
especially with their first kid and they
try to hang on to everything that used
to be and what they do is they end up
getting themselves hurt okay so okay as
you enter the season
if nobody's told you this and they
probably have in their own weird God
have you gotten so much crap ridiculous
advice from everybody
oh God yeah it's in it insane is it wild
it's it's madness has your husband
lectured you yet please say yes
and no he's actually been great okay hey
you're a one percenter dude I had people
giving me advice in the in in the
grocery store a lot like I like I don't
know you why are you talking about my
wife's body weird like it was madness
madness everybody's had advice and
wisdom and blah blah all right here's
the deal if someone tells me to enjoy
the sleep while I can one more time I
might lose it
up in here up in here listen okay
your body will not be your own
okay okay make peace with that
it sucks I've watched I watched my wife
a few times I was like I don't I I don't
know what's happening to your soul
um but feeding lack of sleep feeling
like a zombie insecurity body changes
hormone regulation like hormones playing
pickleball with your emotions just going
bananas right all them you're about to
walk into an industry an entire
ecosystem designed for one thing to make
moms feel guilty so they'll buy crap
you're entering into that world what
kind of soap are you using does it have
parabens in it oh my gosh did you know
that and listen the fact that I just
said that I can't tell you how many DMS
I'm gonna get like well here's the thing
about parabens and yeah anyway you're
gonna you're not gonna be able to rest
it's gonna be chaos and listen that's
okay
it's think about going off the water
park and there's a way to to turn your
mindset if you practice it which is I'm
so tired I can't even I don't know what
day it is I don't know what time it is
what a blessing I've got a healthy kid
and I get to be in this season you see
what I'm saying there's it's going to be
you practicing that mindset shift okay
now
um here's what I think the most
important planning you can do moving
forward
is not about trying to predict
everything that's coming because it's
just so different
um I I think I've told the story on this
show my friend
um my friend John there was I had three
friends and um uh there was two of us
were named John so I was hyper John he
was fat John he's one of my best friends
on planet but John would he had kids
first and whenever his and his wife's
name's Jen she's like one of the
greatest women on planet Earth and
whenever he first had his kid his first
daughter
he quit hanging out with us and we hung
out regularly every Monday night and I
started thinking this is on me I was
like man Jen is killing this guy
like suddenly there's one kid and she
won't let him hang out with the guys
anymore whatever and then he had another
kid and he disappeared and I was like
man
what they need to fix their marriage
dude and then I had Hank
and I'll never forget McGee John and I
were out having Gypsy queso and I was
like uh
dude why didn't you tell me and he just
smiled real big and he said something
like say it and I was like I I always
thought you didn't want to hang out with
us because you weren't allowed because
Jen wasn't allowing you to
you didn't want to hang out with us
because you wanted to sit on your couch
and hold your baby and you'd rather
spend time with that one-year-old than
with us and he was like yep and I said
why didn't you ever tell me and he goes
because I couldn't have explained it you
just have to experience it and so
everybody with their advice and their
wisdom and their yeah all that crap let
that go into What In One Ear smile let
it go out the other because they're
trying to love you the best they can
I think the most important thing you and
your husband can do is set up a
structure
that you commit to before you have a
baby
where you have a road back to one
another on a regular basis what does
that look like in real life every Monday
night we sit down together and say how
are you every Monday night we say we sit
down we ask the same question how can I
love you this week how can I love you
for the next three days because that's
how fast things are changing
and you are gonna have to practice
saying your needs out loud
does that make sense is that fair
yeah it does it makes sense
once I mean four times a week we're
gonna have skin on skin contact that may
end up in us making out it may be I just
need
to feel somebody else's heartbeat other
than that kid
I need somebody not using my body as a
jungle gym I just need to rest in you
can we just hold hands let me put my my
hand on your chest can I just breathe
for for 30 minutes but we're going to do
skin on skin contact four times a week
right
um I promise that we won't be led by our
feelings but we're going to talk about
them you see what I'm saying like we're
going to build a structure so that as
we're building this new life we keep
coming back to one another and we don't
end up in these other planets
does that make sense that is yeah okay
you talk I've been talking a lot
I'm like that already um
I mean more if every day I kind of try
to start the day with you know we both
like what can I do for you today how can
how can I help you today what can you
know just you know something to help the
other person or acknowledge that you
know whatever you like that our needs
change on a day on a what could be a
daily basis I'm just afraid
of um
I think just in the as as I'm getting
further into her arrival and losing
a lot more of my own like this isn't my
body anymore like I don't I don't feel
like myself I'm I feel like I'm having a
hard time I'm starting to have that hard
time of like physically connecting
because I don't feel like I'm at my best
so I'm trying to prep and I I guess
there's no way to really prepare for the
fact that it's like yeah it's not going
to be like when we got married like well
and here's the thing
what I Can't Describe to you on this
side of it
is the feelings are
10x
like I it's hard to say like I promise
you and it sounds crazy but sex will be
better in your 40s than it is in your
20s that sounds insane right I promise
it is
um I promise in the same way you and
um
your husband were like sneaking makeouts
between like not getting caught with
your parents or whatever
you're I hear this from couples all the
time I'm looking at a couple right now
like you're gonna be sneaking make out
so your kids don't catch you and the
same level like right so the same heart
racing and like how are we gonna oh like
your life will just be different it's
not going to be less than in fact it's
going to be infinitely better than it's
just hard to capture that in words right
now and it will be found in stolen
glances and it will be found in Gentle
Touch as you're both reaching for the
same thing in the fridge and it will be
it'll be passing moments of just looking
at each other like in those with like
you look at him and be like oh you got a
whole night of sleep last night I hope
you're happy with yourself and he'll
look at you and say oh you get this you
get to just stay in bed and hold the
baby all day I right and you're gonna
have those moments here's here's the
magic phrase in my house
the story I'm telling myself is and
that's how we preface the conversation
and so I think it would be really really
lovely for your marriage and for you and
for your husband to say the story I'm
telling myself is is that you're you're
not going to think I'm pretty anymore
because I've gained 35 pounds say those
words out loud
the story I'm telling myself is I'm
gonna have a baby you're never going to
want to like make out with me again and
we're gonna turn into one of those
couples that just never has sex and
watches Netflix all the time
the story I'm telling myself is is that
I'm losing control of my body and I
don't know what's happening like say
those things out loud
in a way that's not attacking him
because if you let it all bottle up it
explodes like shaking a two liter right
say it in a way that he can hear it and
um and that's what I say have a
structure don't start don't be like yeah
usually we start every morning
make it put it on the calendar no matter
what come hell or high water Sunday
nights we sit down and talk we go
through our calendar we check in with
one another
the story I'm telling myself is that I
was not a very good dad last week how
can I do how can I step it up
and the story I'm telling myself is you
keep saying stupid things and the story
I'm saying myself is you're actually
stupid right instead of I'm just a
clueless dad and I don't know I'm trying
my best I'm reading all the books I ask
my friends listen Sarah I went to all of
the the baby classes with my wife I went
to all those things I went to as many of
her doctor appointments as I could I
wanted to be the Super hip Ultra Modern
dad like I'm all in
nobody told me that my kids would crap a
hundred thousand times in a single day I
had no idea I thought they'd go twice
like a normal person they don't and so
he's gonna say God Almighty how many
diapers are we buying and you're gonna
think
well if you were just around and plugged
into your daughter and you weren't so
busy right and that's how that and then
all of a sudden boom you create two
separate lives right there
and so being able to go
yeah he didn't know and he actually is
trying really hard he just didn't know
and in fact you could say I thought they
would do it like five times I didn't
know it was 19.
um y'all can sit down and say the story
I'm telling myself is you're not plugged
into our daughter and he can say I'm
reading I'm listening I'm talking to
people I just can't keep up I don't know
it's all happening so fast and that
vulnerability is going to be where y'all
stay connected and build something
completely new
does that make sense okay
yeah that makes a lot of sense actually
that makes me feel a lot better so it's
a it's a weird thing
um one of my great mentors Randy Harris
gave me this analogy one time
it's like you are swinging through the
jungle on a vine
and you are just realizing that your
Vine is about to run out of Swing
and so you let go and the other Vine you
don't see it coming through all the
leaves and trees
and you look up though and you can see
on that tree there's a whole bunch of
other people up there and they made it
so you know the vines come and you just
gotta let go and believe that it's on
its way
that's where you're entering into
and the more you try to over predict and
over
guesstimate and over dream about what
this is going to look and feel like
the more disorienting it's going to be
when reality hits and it's very very
different and it doesn't feel like that
at all
so
go off the ride let go head down that
slide and enjoy that ride
and oh my gosh that was I'm basically a
rapper I I was incredible
um I'm also putting out a hip-hop record
after this if you guys want to pick it
up
um
I I want you to enjoy the ride and make
sure you're staying plugged in to your
husband the whole way
with your fears with your concerns with
your ability to say your needs out loud
and just look at the countless folks
like us on the other side smiling saying
dude it's so incredible it's so
incredible we can't wait to see it on
this side of it let us know how your
baby goes send us a picture and we'll
make sure we announce especially if you
name it Jonah that's a great daughter's
name thank you so much Sarah we'll be
right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of would
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right let's go to Devin in Post
Falls what's up Devin
how's it going partying man
what are you up to
uh just standing outside excited for
this phone call uh is it cold
yes dude go inside man I'm not worth
pneumonia
oh no it's fine it's nice to get the
fresh air
um I was actually in Nashville Tennessee
uh this last week and the weather there
was much nicer
I mean so what's up brother how can I
help
so I've made over the last
I don't know 10 months 12 months I've
made a lot of changes in my life uh I
switched jobs I've changed the people
who I hang around with uh quit drinking
and then I think the biggest thing is I
lost I'm at about 115 pounds now what uh
you've lost 115 pounds in 10 months
yeah homie dude that's incredible man
way to go
what what sparked this change please say
my show please
uh actually that did have a lot to do it
did and I'm fine it didn't know this
book
uh your your book to own your past
change your future when I decided that I
needed to do something different because
I'm 32 now and I was kind of at a
stalemate I can't just do the same thing
my whole life and my brother recommended
it we go okay didn't really think much
of it and listen to it picked up a
little bit a little bit more
um so I think that that helped me
realize that there were things inside of
me that I needed to work on not just oh
you need to lose weight like there's a
reason why I was like that
it's awesome dude I'm so PR I can't I'm
so proud of you dude it's amazing that's
incredible thank you it's incredible
dude
I feel much better and healthier now I
bet you can stand outside and it's zero
degrees and talk on the phone that's
amazing man I'm so bad I'm so proud of
you it's awesome
um thank you and uh let's don't blow by
this like losing weights really hard
it's one of the biggest challenges
stopping drinking is really hard I
actually think underneath what you've
done the hardest thing you've done is
you've changed your Social Circles
that's real hard man making friends when
you're 30 is the worst
the worst right good thing that's hard
you've done a lot of hard stuff man I'm
so proud of you dude that's amazing
thank you
um and now I feel like I'm I'm at this
point where I want to change some more
things I want to I guess I'm looking at
my future more than I ever used to
because it
just like I see things for myself like I
need to be a better person and whatever
and now like with the weight loss it was
it was easy to set goals and meet these
markers and
now I'm kind of
I feel like I'm overthinking everything
I'll look at a different career I'm like
oh I can maybe do that but there's these
downsides and
it sorry sorry I'm rambling a little oh
you're not rambling it's harder for me
to
feel like I'm confidently making those
decisions versus is this just going to
be another
decision I make that doesn't ultimately
help me to get to where I want to be
okay so yeah man
what you are asking is such an important
question that I think quite frankly our
culture misses dramatically okay I'm so
grateful that you called a so we could
celebrate your successes it's amazing
but two
um
you've entered into this really
important world where we don't have a
psychology for this in our culture and
here's what it is I think
um where you want to go your
quote-unquote goals those are important
but they're often the wrong question
here's what I mean by that
um the number of times I go work with
Business Leaders all across the country
and we get behind closed doors and we
have some hard conversations about their
numbers and their books and their
personnel all that kind of stuff
and I'm just going to make up numbers
here but let's say it's real easy to get
have a strategic planning
um opportunity sit down look at your
numbers dream big come up with the b-hag
they call it the big hairy audacious
goal and to say we're going to be a 500
million dollar company that's our goal
that's what we're gonna go do come like
we're crushing it we're killing that's
our goal
what you've accidentally done is you
have set a metric
that does not take into account covid or
inflation or hey we don't have any glass
because of uh supply chain issues
and so instead of doing the hard work
which is saying here's who we're gonna
be
on the way to wherever it is we're going
that's way harder to do and to see
through
because then what happens is you have
employees that the world shifts
underneath you but you still got that
500 that 500 million dollar Benchmark
out there so they start cutting Corners
they start making a little bit of a
worse loan than they would otherwise and
they don't tell anybody about it or they
somehow get it through committee all hey
I'll say yes to this loan if you'll say
yes to my loan and let's go ahead and
bundle and sell these loans and now
you've you've got people doing whatever
it takes to hit that quote unquote goal
and you've you've had a goal my guess is
I'm gonna lose 100 pounds or whatever
if you're not careful you start starving
yourself
or you start taking a bunch of not good
medicine from the doctor some really
extraordinary medicine out there now for
weight loss but you start just taking a
bunch of amphetamines and you see what
I'm saying like you'll cut Corners to
get there
and you start cheating away in days and
all of a sudden you get your number
but you don't like who you are when you
get there or you get your number and
everything around using Ash you see what
I'm saying so you've made so what you've
proven to yourself is that in one year
Devin can do freaking anything
okay you've tackled the three big hard
the hardest things I know of alcohol
weight loss and friend circles you did
it all
so in terms of like who do I want on my
on my team who do I want to go into
battle with
you're first right because if I if if if
you say I'll get to the other side of
that line I 100 know you're gonna get
there okay so
you're always going to have
opportunities for jobs because there's
not a job on Earth that doesn't want a
guy like you on that team
what you've got to stop doing but you
you can't seek that approval
what you have to do is just ask yourself
the hard question is
who do I want to be to wherever wherever
it is I'm going
and this goes back to Identity
I'm a guy who takes care of his body
and at some point my body's gonna stop
losing weight I am going to have to I'm
gonna start lifting I'm gonna try this
out I might start running some
regardless of what those little mini
goals are I'm gonna run a half marathon
one day or I'm gonna walk uh whatever
I'm gonna I want to bench press this
much weight all those goals are fine
but they're in service to I'm a guy
who's a good Steward of his body
and occasionally like I that's one of my
identities like I'm a guy who takes care
of his his body so that I can be a good
dad so I can be a good employee so that
I can work really hard and show up
and the last like a couple of months I
think I've talked about the show I was
finishing up a book and I had to check
myself into a hotel a few times and just
write 24 7 and finish this thing in that
season I did not was not a good Steward
of my body my body worked really hard I
redlined it and so now I'm putting money
back in the bank right I'm trying to
take care of myself I'm gonna season it
so it goes and Seasons it's all good but
it's all in service to this identity so
let me ask you
you've proven to yourself I could do
anything
who do you want to be now what kind of
Life do you want to have do you want to
have a funny life an adventurous life a
life that you are just going to spend
the next five years grinding it out
working really hard making a bunch of
money like what what do you what do you
want what do you want to feel like
I
I just
hmm
you know that's a good question
I
I like to help people I kind of looked
towards like first responder type thing
because I
I feel like there was times in my life
where I
maybe could have used some help or maybe
there was people that were there to help
and I didn't reach out but I don't it
just
I like to do things like that
um
I don't know so let me tell you this so
um one of my identities that I've I've
taken on
and I got this from a mentor
is I want people to be a little more
peaceful after they get done interacting
with me than before
and what that frees me up is if I choose
to go be a first responder and just quit
this job
that still applies
if I go back to working at Burger King
where I worked when I was in high school
My Hope Is I can have a inject a little
bit of humanity into that exchange when
they're buying their Whopper with cheese
or whatever
and I hope that that person's a little
more peaceful a little more joyful a
little more Smiley after they interact
with me than before
and so you like to help people
I want you to go one step deeper and
begin to ask yourself
how do I want people to experience me
and I want you to keep this this just
tattoo this on your heart from this
point forward because you've proven all
you need to prove
I want you to tattoo this on your soul
it's about identity not destination
because you're going to end up where if
you wherever you end up you can't do
anything about the world economy
imploding or like chat GPT could be
coming the next internet and we all make
even more money than we've made the last
25 years right you can't or gas prices
going up to 500 a gallon you can't you
can't do anything about those things
zero
and so the important energy I want you
to spend is who do I want to be or
wherever it is I'm going
I want to be a guy this is this is Deb
this is me telling you I want to be a
guy that has a reputation for working
really hard and always getting the job
done no matter what
I want that okay so that means I gotta
take care of my body that means I gotta
get enough sleep that means I gotta have
friends and community in my in my in my
corner that also means and I struggle
with this I gotta be on time
I have to always meet my deadlines right
so all I have to say is that's one of my
so I want you to get four or five or six
identities here's who I'm gonna be
Here's Where I Wanna Be in this next
phase and the beauty of what you have is
most people start those identities at
the beginning of this 10-month journey
you did it without it you just said I'm
I'm going all in so now you can create
these you can lay out these identities
and begin to backfill the action steps
you need to take
with no reservation you've got no
Governor because you can do it freaking
anything Devin
that does make sense I
okay
uh I was just hoping for like you should
go working in banking right
that that has been a consideration I did
some CPA classes and stuff when I was in
high school got some college credits
like I tend to do well in that kind of
stuff I just
Devin I'm telling you I'm telling you
right now
I've hired more people than I can count
I can't tell you how many people have
hired over my career
I can also can't tell you how many
people I've consulted how many
businesses all from plumbers to colleges
to all everybody in between
you will never long for a job
because they don't make people like you
there's very few of you out there
and I'm convinced that you can get put
as a technical writer and you hate
writing and you don't like grammar and
you would do well you'd figure it out it
might take a little bit of your soul I'm
really really good at Big budgets at
dealing with budgets
and it takes a little bit of my soul
every time I do it right every time I
hit submit I I it part of me dies a
little bit but I can do it real well
you can do whatever you want to I'm
gonna send you my buddy Ken Coleman has
a get clear assessment that kind of
narrows it down it helps you start to
link this identity with what are some
things that I would be really good at
I'm going to send it to you for free and
I want you to utilize that I'm also
going to send you his book from paycheck
to purpose and that is a like okay I got
all these skills
where can I go and purpose is really I I
love how my friend Jade Simmons says it
purpose is how I other people experience
me
purpose is what I Inspire in other
people
and this is gonna keep you from going I
just need another job any other job any
other career too
what were you put on this Earth to do
man
and I actually don't think that's one
thing I think that's a way of being I
think that's an identity but that's just
me
um what was I put her to do
how am I gonna go make that happen who
am I gonna be on this journey
and dude it's it can be paralyzing
because now the the whole field is open
you kind of run where you want to run
and you've proven to everybody you're
real real fast
question you gotta ask yourself is who
am I gonna be wherever it is I'm going
and dude I cannot wait to see where you
end up the world needs more people like
you my brother and an honor I've gotten
to spend some time with you we'll be
right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show the
great David Bowie will take us out with
his classic oh sorry Bowie
David Bowie if you're from Texas it's a
buoy knife but I guess but he wasn't the
buoy that it's named after this is David
Bowie that's enough of you it's it's
David Bowie
song's called changes
still don't know what I was waiting for
and my time is running wild a million
dead in streets and every time I thought
I got it made it seemed The Taste was
not so sweet so I turned myself to face
me but I've never caught a glimpse of
how the others must see the faker I'm
too fast to take the test I'm much too
fast take the test changes
changes it's gonna have to be a
different man time may change me
but I can't change time love it we'll
see you soon
[Music]